today Senate Republicans said that
they're looking forward to hearing
president Trump's side of the story yeah
yeah which means I guess they're not on
Twitter that's all he does been he's
been tweeting non-stop right 700 he's
pretty much told us everything he thinks
while sitting on a toilet in Switzerland
a protester interrupted yesterday's
impeachment proceedings yelling Schumer
is the devil the protester was escorted
out of the room and immediately on to
Trump's legal team
a I love walking off camera I enjoy
that's my quiet time yeah yeah away from
America all right now that's where you
can cry one tear yeah exactly they get
back out and then I can come back and be
the clown again a company in Finland is
making food using only water electricity
and air yeah today the company admitted
it's not good food that was plenty for
that one and I can't believe this is
crazy stories scientists have discovered
a new breed of shark that can walk
through story yeah yeah meanwhile sharks
have discovered a new breed of
scientists that can [ __ ] its pants do
you see how it comes together
[Applause]